good morning john it's thursday so
remarkably we have mostly forgotten
about this by now but there was a day
this week when a lot of people had the
thought facebook has been down for a
really long time now
maybe it won't come back that was
accompanied by this tweet getting 400
000 likes and retweets so someone
deleted large sections of the routing
that doesn't mean that facebook is just
down from the looks of it that means
that facebook is gone several people
then wrote blog posts about how facebook
might be gone because of a tweet from
someone who is not qualified to comment
on it because like that would be the
most interesting piece of news that day
and i'm sure it got a lot of impressions
which i guess is the goal though it does
rely on a complete misunderstanding of
how websites work so maybe that's lesson
number one while something is happening
is the worst time to learn about it but
it is also the time when we most want to
know about it and that is the root of
one of many different destructive
mechanisms that happen on social media
has nothing to do with what platform
you're on it has to do with the barriers
to distribution and discovery being low
enough to ice skate over this song came
on the back of francis haugen a former
facebook employee releasing a huge trove
of documents in which facebook did
research on itself and discovered that
it was
you know not great research that it then
promptly ignored and kind of hid so
facebook's no good very bad week gave us
a chance to think uh what if it didn't
exist but actually a lot of people
really do depend on facebook to maintain
their businesses their social lives
their families their connections with
people and other countries who they love
i'm just saying maybe don't go to the
people who are gleefully celebrating to
be the ones who have the best insight on
this topic but i do think it's important
to engage in a thoughtful way with the
existence of facebook the impact of
facebook hence this very long
educational video which makes it exempt
from the four-minute vlogbrothers room
now i have over the years been vocally
critical of facebook for a number of
different reasons so you might expect me
to just like launch out with how bad an
evil it is oh just a fun little social
network that undermines the foundations
of our democracy and lets me know when
my dad is done building the debt why
would those two things be put together
i don't know
[Music]
when justin timberlake was bringing sexy
back 15 years ago when i was a
full-fledged adult facebook was only
available to high school and college
students now it is the sixth most
valuable corporation in the world and
possibly the most influential
corporation
ever like yes there have been newspaper
monopolies that controlled the news
there's been energy monopolies that
controlled energy there have been
telephone monopolies that controlled
long distance communication but facebook
might know more about you than you do
like their internal research has shown
that they can affect people's moods they
can decide whether to inform or
misinform you they can help a community
thrive they can make a community stop
existing and they can do that not just
with like 60 000 people like the signs
of missoula they do it with billions
billions of people you start thinking
about this too hard and you realize that
mark zuckerberg might be the most
powerful person to exist which is not a
super comforting thought facebook has a
lot of power like a coalition of
european politicians on both sides of
whatever they have i guess an aisle
probably do they have an island they
wrote to facebook and they said your
platform is forcing us into more extreme
positions than we want to have and maybe
even that our constituents want us to
have because in order to get elected we
have to play the attention and
engagement game that you have set up for
us now you might say well those
politicians should have some spine and
do what they want to do rather than what
like the mass of people on facebook want
them to do but let's all accept together
that a politician's incentive is to get
elected and if they don't engage in the
attention game and someone else does
they don't get elected and then that
person is in power look it's easy to not
be sympathetic toward politicians i get
that but i am also very aware that there
are probably a lot of people who would
be very good public servants who are not
ever going to consider taking on that
line of work because of the environment
that the social internet has created
these platforms make life miserable for
every politician who is not a garbage
human
[Music]
we are at the very beginning of this it
always feels in any given moment i'm old
enough now to recognize this it always
feels like where we are is the
destination we have arrived at this
moment and that is where we were going
and then that turns out to be not true
this moment ends up being another step
on the journey to the other place where
we were going which is the new present
that we will experience in the future so
i'm just trying to remember that we are
at the very very very beginning of this
if you ask someone what the most
disruptive technologies in history are
they are probably going to tell you
about some weapon which i get but i
think the most disruptive human
technologies are always communications
technologies ways that people transmit
information from person to person
stories and books and plays and trade
and radio and television radio was
fantastic for the nazis the catholic
church was fractured by the printing
press i used to think that i
irrationally believed that the social
internet was as big of a deal as the
printing press
i now believe that that is 100
irrational belief
in fact it feels like a common belief
now and so if we are at the beginning of
this and it is a huge revolution in like
the main human thing which is human to
human communication
then like
it shouldn't be a surprise that we're
bad at this and we're bad at this i'm
sorry if you work at one of these
companies but we need to accept this
facebook and twitter and tick tock and
youtube
are bad at this and you watching this
are bad at it and i
making this am bad at it of course we're
bad at it it's revolutionary and it's a
baby we have no systems for how to deal
with many too many decentralized
communication it's brand new we don't
know what we're doing so as with
apparently everything uh we have to
figure it out and that means that some
not all but some
thoughtful people need to engage with it
in a serious way and if you're watching
this maybe you're one of those people
and actually i was a little bit
impressed by the congressional hearing
that the testimony that francis haugen
the facebook whistleblower gave and the
questions that were asked it seemed to
me to show a much deeper understanding
of how all of this works than i had
previously seen it means maybe we're
starting to have useful conversations
about how to live in a society that
contains social media and look it is
very easy to say facebook sucks i say it
all the time but it is much harder to
imagine uh what one would do to make
facebook better because guess what like
apologies to the random bloggers who
thought that facebook was gonna not
exist anymore it's gonna keep existing
if mark zuckerberg wanted to just like
pull the plug and be like well what a
great experiment we're not gonna do it
anymore that would be a hundo p baller
move but it does seem unlikely like i
feel like mark zuckerberg has a lot of
incentives to believe that facebook does
more good than harm and so he's probably
gonna believe that whether or not it's
true which is actually for clarity not
something i know honestly i'm not even
sure many people could even answer the
question
what is facebook
[Music]
let's try and build a mental model of
what facebook actually is i'm not saying
it's going to be perfect but i am saying
that it's probably going to be better
than whatever jungle of hot takes you
currently have associated with your
facebook neuron facebook simplified
there are three centers of power there
are the people who consume the content
the people who create the content and
the people who host and promote the
content that third one is facebook
this thinker i'm not flicking off
facebook all three of these groups have
different goals but it turns out that
their incentives align really well which
is how facebook became worth a trillion
dollars so let's go over the incentives
let's try to understand why these people
are all doing what they're doing
starting with the people who create the
content they are trying to make their
numbers go up whether that is for status
or for money and trust me when i say uh
watching the numbers go up can feel
really good and once you start to get
them it can take a whole lot of time and
work to start divorcing your self-worth
from your internet numbers facebook
needs to incentivize the creation of
content on its platform because without
that there's nothing there for people to
do and so they provide a lot of
different feedback mechanisms that make
people feel good about the stuff that
they make that make people feel like
they are acquiring status and very
occasionally that they are getting
revenue next let's talk about the people
who consume the content which is to say
everyone and let us all
accept that we as people who consume
content have incentives for what content
we consume we like good cats we like
good jokes there are a number of
different incentive cycles here but the
ones that we tend to talk about and need
to talk about most are the ones that are
destructive to society or to people who
are consuming the content and the number
one emotion everyone talks about when
talking about this is outrage and i
would like us to stop talking about
outrage because i don't know what it is
instead i would like to talk about two
other things one is fear people when
they are afraid uh experience a lot of
emotion and they experience a lot of
desire to share that information and and
try and take on that thing that they are
afraid of which like we knew about that
i mean we knew about that before social
media like news was always aware of fear
but the second thing that social media
is very good at that we often call
outrage is actually a feeling of
righteous superiority i feel really good
about myself because i know that i am
better than whatever other human i have
just been exposed to or told about
feeling like a good person who is
specifically good because they are
better than someone else
super
seductive because it means you don't
have to do anything
to be good you get to feel better about
yourself just by looking at how awful
other people are but it is not new like
i don't want to point fingers or
anything but it turns out that righteous
superiority was a pretty big deal for
martin luther and also people are often
correct in their righteousness and in
their superiority like hello vegans and
finally the last player in the game the
platform itself their incentive is or at
least was very clear keep people on the
platform learn more about them so you
can sell more advertisements at a higher
price and so there's a positive feedback
loop where platforms will promote
content that makes people feel
righteously superior those people will
consume that content they will feel
righteously superior more people will
create that content because it will do
better because the platform will promote
it more and there's also external
positive feedbacks into the loop because
if you have a group of people feeling
righteously superior other people find
out about them and then they make
themselves feel righteously superior to
that other group because they don't want
to feel inferior i don't want to
oversimplify this but like if you run
this positive feedback loop for about 10
years maybe you end up with everyone
spun up like a bunch of beyblades thrown
into a fishbowl full of fragile
institutions there are also other
feedback loops which is why there are
cute cats and good jokes on all of these
platforms but hopefully this gives us a
workable mental model of what facebook
is and we can move to the next section
of the video
we've got these three power centers and
two of them are extremely dispersed and
difficult to control like no one is able
no one is able to control what people
are posting and consuming on social
media platforms but the third one is
centralized and it's making 85 billion
dollars a year so that makes it a more
attractive target both in terms of
optics and also in terms of something
you can actually control for regulators
you might have even seen or heard
facebook kind of begging to be regulated
which sounds strange here for example is
the end of a statement that facebook
made in response to francis haugen
sharing all this information about the
platform despite all this all this being
the fact that they don't agree with
anything she said we agree on one thing
it's time to begin to create standard
rules for the internet it's been 25
years since the rules for the internet
have been updated and instead of
expecting the industry to make societal
decisions that belong to legislators
it's time for congress to act this is a
good point like it's a good talking
point it's also just a good point but
let me explain why you're going to be
hearing a lot of it and why it might not
be as good as it sounds this is facebook
saying okay i see that you think that
we've created a lot of problems how
about you fix them are we going to give
you advice into how to fix them nah are
we going to give you insight that will
allow you to understand the platform
well enough to create good solutions
also they're basically saying okay i see
you i see what you're doing you're
saying that we're the big bad and the
responsibilities on us we're saying what
about you what we think you're the big
bad the responsibility should be on you
and maybe it should right like should
facebook's responsibility be to like
impose things that control society or
should that be the job of legislators
but this outlines a really good and
interesting point which is that facebook
is actually with regards to this stuff
not like anything else they're doing
fine with regards to this stuff they're
kind of in a terrible position so a
company as big and powerful as facebook
can kind of have one of two goals it can
either be out there for profit or it
could be out there for profit
and
and what and is gets really complicated
when you are as powerful as faith and i
think maybe this conversation kind of
terrifies them because it outlines a
reality that they would like us to not
notice they are not just a place where
content goes they decide what people see
they make millions of decisions per
second about the world that people
experience and it is very easy to make
those decisions when you have a
particular goal that goal being how do
we keep people on the site longer learn
more about them so we can tell them more
effective advertisements and then you
can start to put on some little limits
like if this is gonna incite violence if
it's hate speech we're gonna take that
off uh but that's just about the law and
like what what the right thing to do is
but if you get beyond that and you start
to say okay well sort of what counts as
hate speech what counts as incitement to
violence and raising up the barriers
higher and higher and being like ah
that's on the line but we're going to
call it incitement to violence
that's going to constrict the speech of
some people more than others
particularly it's going to constrict the
speech of some members of certain
political parties than others and of
course they can legally do that they're
a private company
until they can't anymore you're already
seeing this like right-wing politicians
getting up there and saying like people
are being censored on social media in a
way that of course makes their
constituents feel both afraid and
righteously superior what a win and many
of them are threatening a whole set of
separate regulations that would prevent
these social media platforms from
policing themselves which for clarity
would be it would be a disaster so
facebook is saying if you want us to do
something tell us what to do because
we're afraid that if we do more than the
bare minimum you're gonna regulate away
our ability to do anything at all so
until you make that call we'd rather
just do what is normal and expected of a
corporation which is to focus on profit
now there are also other reasons why
facebook is focusing on this
conversation about regulation one is
that it means that it would regulate all
internet companies not just facebook the
rules of the internet not the rules of
facebook and regulations are often
actually a competitive advantage for
existing incumbent large businesses over
potential competitors because the
regulations increase the barrier to
entry into that industry i'm not saying
i'm anti-regulation on these companies
i'm very pro-regulation on these
companies i'm just not so pro-regulation
on these companies that i will ignore
reality but the last and maybe most
important reason why facebook is calling
for regulation on itself is that then
they get to go after the individual
actual pieces of legislation like the
individual suggestions which they will
of course do like yes please regulate us
but then any individual regulation they
will fight against tooth and nail and
yes it is a lot easier for a legislator
to just like yell about how much
facebook sucks than to actually write
legislation that would make it better
especially when regulation is
complicated whereas shouting that
facebook sucks can make them and their
constituents feel wait for it
righteously superior none of this
regulation would be easy because yes
legally facebook can control its product
in whatever way it wants to but let's
accept that it's not just a private
corporation in that way anymore like we
don't want it to be able to control
society in whatever way it wants and
that that is why they're sort of very
hesitant to do that because it's
terrifying facebook is a place where
communities thrive where families
connect where businesses grow in a very
real sense it is kind of both
corporation and government like if you
spend a lot of time on facebook a lot of
your life there
they are in charge of that part of your
life that makes them a kind of
government a fact that they would like
everyone to keep not realizing for as
long as possible because
it has implications
oh my god i've been recording for 50
minutes now what the hell did i do to
myself i do have more that i need to say
here i've implied this already but i'm
going to say it out loud right now the
real danger and power and weakness of
facebook and youtube and tiktok and
twitter is not
that they host content it's that they
decide what content
gets new eyeballs on it hosting a piece
of content is the the building block
that the entire internet was built on
promoting content is an active editorial
decision that is being made by the
company now that decision might be being
made by a computer program that no one
understands that only has inputs from
the users of the platform it is still a
decision that the company makes and so
when a hateful facebook group gets
promoted when there's an anti-vaxx
talking point trending on the side of
twitter and watching a youtube video
about history takes you into the
alt-right pipeline those are decisions
that are made by platforms
full of thoughtful people who did not
think at all about the fact that that
was going to be a thing that happened
this is a problem with every social
media platform that uses algorithms like
you can scroll all day on tick tock and
it will just be full of people
celebrating the diversity of humankind
and their own remarkable human body and
mind and you will never be exposed to
the garbage terrible alt-right pipeline
inside of tick-tock because tick-tock is
really good at knowing who you are what
i'm saying is when people say that
facebook should be held responsible for
the content that's on its platform i
agree but in a pretty limited way like
they should not host hate speech they
should not host illegal content but i
believe that in a much more limited
number of cases than the following
sentence facebook should be held
responsible for the content that it
promotes on its platform i think that
that is something that every single
person who works at a social media
company needs to square with and it's
not an easy thing because it is very
difficult to create that joyous
wonderful experience that you might have
on on an algorithmic feed without
indulging in other people's righteous
superiority and their fear in a way that
continues to spin us up create division
and destroy fragile institutions in
general a algorithmic content platform's
response to this situation is okay let's
create artificial intelligences that can
identify hate speech they can identify
incitement to violence and then we will
take down those individual things but
we're gonna leave up this remarkable
self-reinforcing feedback loop that is
so fantastic at keeping people engaged
on our platform which is a little like
saying we're gonna like follow behind
the dune buggy full of flamethrowers and
put out the fires that it's creating
yeah guys you gotta focus on the dune
buggy with the flamethrower and that is
a conversation that i actually feel like
is starting to happen
[Music]
now i feel like it's necessary to say
there are people who are smart and who i
respect who say that when you talk about
regulating social media companies you're
not talking about regulating media
you're talking about regulating society
and we don't want the government to
regulate society that's scary my
response to that argument is that
facebook is already regulating society
it is just doing it with a very
narrow
short-term focus which is how do we
increase the amount that we know about
people
and the amount of time they spend on our
platform so that we can make more money
advertising to them
i wish at the end of this video that i
had
like good advice for how to move forward
like i think that
we're not going to educate people out of
um you know response to fear and
indulgence in righteous superiority but
there are some signs that maybe like
immunities do kick in and some people
not like think about this actively but
realize that like ah that kind of
content seems like overplayed but we
can't say like facebook is only bad
because humans make bad decisions
because like humans are humans and we're
not gonna get out of that it might be
that these platforms start to get their
platforms to recognize
when
they are engaging in the promotion of
societally or personally destructive
content i encourage all computer
scientists to work on that problem i
think that we need to say to ourselves
it would be very hard for facebook to
make a profit in a world that has been
completely ripped apart by facebook and
as for what legislators should do i
don't know i'm not thank goodness i
don't have your job but i will say i'm
very much not in favor of making it so
that platforms are ultimately
responsible for like anything that gets
posted on their platform that would
basically make it so that none of these
things could exist at all
but i am in favor of saying that they
are responsible for what they promote on
their platforms because that is their
decision i don't know if the world would
be better without this many to many
decentralized communication system that
we have developed i know my life would
be very different without it but i will
reiterate something i said earlier which
is that we are at the very very
beginning of this of course we are bad
at we're going to look back in 20 or 30
years at the way things are right now
and we're going to think about how
quaint and clunky and just hilariously
bad it was i don't know how we're gonna
move forward from here but i know that
we will john i'll see you on tuesday all
of our lovely pizzama stuff is available
only during pizzamas so for the next
week or so and then it will never be
available again none of it will ever be
available again you can go to
pizzamist.com right now to check it out
all the profits go to support our
community's work developing better
health care systems in sierra leone